[Music]
in his book ghost wars pulitzer
prize-winning journalist steve calm
looked at osama bin laden's time in
afghanistan from the early 1980s up to
the eve of the attacks on 9 11.
in his latest the bin ladens mr kaul
writes about the history of the bin
laden family its rise to prominence in
saudi arabia and the influence of the
family in the world today
mr cole discusses his new book with
michael shoyer former head of the bin
laden unit at the cia
and the author most recently of marching
toward hell america and islam after iraq
[Music]
steve it's a great pleasure to be here
with you
to talk about your new book
the bin ladens
i think
surely you have a unique perspective
amongst
uh american authors for south asia your
previous books ghost wars were you know
a terrific book on the afghan war
against the soviets and
one of my personal favorites of on the
grand trunk road i thought that was a
wonderful book to explain south asia to
americans
the current book i guess we should start
why did you why did you spend so much
time and effort on the bin ladens
well i
like you spent a long time
working on the subject of osama i wrote
my first newspaper story about him in
1993 and in ghost wars i treated him
some in the context of the
afghan war and tried to write a little
bit about saudi arabia and its
involvement in
um
that in his life and in his his jihadism
on the frontier but i always felt as a
reporter even though i came and went
from the kingdom many times that i that
i sort of bounced off the subject a lot
it's a very difficult place to work as
you know i just you don't have any
points of entry there's no free press
there's no
free scholarship there's no political
opposition and
and yet i always felt that there was
more
to understand something more specific
and complicated to try to unpack in
saudi arabia and that the family its
history in the 20th century might
provide
a vehicle for that i used to read and
like books that would just be called the
rockefellers or
the kennedys
and that was the that was the framework
that i that i had in mind it's certainly
a wonderful story in in the sense of uh
the founder of the family i think
that's that's something worth commenting
on he's just an extraordinary figure he
really is there's a really there's a
kind of a streak of charismatic genius
that runs through the family really and
it begins with him and uh he
mohammed bin laden was essentially
orphaned with his brother in the
hadramata
famine-stricken area of southern yemen
around the turn of the century and like
many hadramis
which is a very vigorous diaspora not so
well known in the west but very well
known in the islamic world
through that network he and his brother
essentially walked out of this remote
canyon found their way to the sea
boarded a vote boat and sailed to saudi
arabia and
they arrived in jitta at the cusp of the
depression and he sort of hustled his
way through the first
period of his time in saudi arabia
the 30s were not a very
prosperous time
but he learned how to be a mason and
started a small contracting company
worked for a ramco for a while
and at the end of the second world war
when
international commerce opened up again
and saudi arabia finally began to enjoy
its the the rewards of its oil wealth
that was when you really started to take
off as a builder it struck me i i think
your your point is very well taken about
the muhammad bin laden in the in the
yemenis being hustlers almost in the
american sense anything to make a buck
and to move on from there for your
family for your business it's a very
um there's not very many things in saudi
arabia that you can
have an analogy with americans but the
the entrepreneurial efforts of the
hadrami's is amazing yes yeah and then
also the kind of sense of
international the kind of transnational
diaspora like the overseas chinese or uh
you know or the jewish diaspora over
centuries you know a sense of belonging
but not really tied down to any
territory able to establish themselves
in lots of different places and and and
i think muhammad used those networks to
get to saudi arabia and to get himself
established so he wasn't entirely alone
but he did have this entrepreneurial
ability and talent absolutely and it the
the other thing i found interesting in
the book uh and very
uh eloquent in terms of this the the
stratification of saudi society is
your point that no matter how successful
the bin ladens were and how much they
were related or not related but dealing
with the royal family they were still
the hired help yeah they were like the
sicilian contractor at some wasp bankers
building his southern home you know
admiring his work ethic but you know
don't don't let him near the daughters
yes sort of thing and as you know saudi
arabia is a place that's
eve even
in the era among arab societies just
unusually focused on genealogy and
status of birth and it's all about the
tribes in the center of the country and
the next and if you're an outsider
to that circle
you're never going to penetrate it it
would be easier for bin laden to marry
an american or a european than to marry
one of the
royal fam into one of the natural royal
families well and certainly your book
shows that they were not reluctant to
marry europeans
that's right exactly sometimes they
regret it but absolutely
one point that comes through very
clearly in your book and i think it's a
point that
americans tend not to understand we tend
to conflate
westernization and modernization or
secularization and modernization and i
think that's one of the very strong
points in your book is that
while one is resisted secularization the
other is
not only
wanted but pursued with great vigor yes
exactly and and this
theme of modernization in the bin laden
family i think is the dominant one along
with this kind of border crossing in uh
sort of transnational aspect of the
family and
and as you say the pursuit of
modernization among
uh different wings of the bin laden
family you know sort of looks to be um
going in very different directions but
in the end there's more commonality
there than than difference i mean
osama's own
use of modern technology is of course a
key to his success as a tactical
innovator he uses the satellite phone
and and he uses aviation to cross border
strike targets that would be reachable
and and he's you know he's an innovator
and so you ask where does that come from
well you look at what his family's doing
at the same time he's using sat phones
to to attack embassies thousands of
miles away
uh other family members have already
been innovating in a more peaceful
commercial sense yes satellite
technology and and so on so
this this kind of image of osama we
always tend not uh everyone but too
often we kind of
put him in his cave and and just dismiss
him as a medieval figure when in fact he
is a he's a product of modernity he's
quite a modern man i think and and
that's you know i i don't want to spend
the whole time or even a large part of
the time talking about osama but
what interested me having done some work
of my own is
how did he sort through
where to come down on osama between the
testimony for example of peter bergen's
fine book on the osama bin laden i know
right and the the
the
uh testimony of people who actually grew
up with him or or knew him at various
points and the people i'm talking i'm
thinking about especially are
ahmed badib
and jamal khashoggi right
mohammed jamal khalifa and
there's almost it has almost seemed to
me over time that the saudis have tried
to have it both ways
regarding osama that when he was young
he was very religious and very helpful
and fought the soviets and now he's gone
crazy right and uh
there's kind of two different camps of
witnesses and i you i thought you
handled it very well in the book but
it's a hard problem it is a hard problem
and and each of these cases you know
like all because it's there's there's
such a limited body of evidence about
his biography that's the thing that's
striking and you know you scrap and and
and scratch and scrape and you get off
one new increment of partially reliable
testimony and you know and you say boy i
just spent six months trying to get this
and that's all there is but
i think when you add it all together and
you and you sit with it and you and you
read it and re-read it and and think it
through there are some strands of
continuity uh in the in the evidence and
and i i thought myself what what really
struck me i should have known this and
maybe i did know it and just
rediscovered it but
what was really striking to me this time
through his life was to recognize in the
context of his relationship with his
brothers to be reminded
in total what an orthodox figure he was
in a saudi context there was nothing we
think of him as you know radical he
became radical and but his radicalism
was itself a form of orthodoxy in you
know he was a nudge and more ardent and
more of a
stickler for prayer and ritual than some
of his brothers preferred especially
those who spent their time in europe but
there was nothing about his
his membership in the muslim brotherhood
or his
religious practices or his collaboration
with the saudi intelligence services in
afghanistan that was you know out of
bounds it was in fact a source of some
pride i think admirable and from their
perspective very admirable and i think
it's a it's kind of a measure of how
successful
how how really
talented the saudis are at
propagandizing the american people that
the american people don't realize that
osama bin laden is really the poster boy
for the saudi educational system he's
not as you said he is not an aberration
right he's not a deviant you know he's
no and it's it it and if anything the
school where he was radicalized
represented the more progressive wing of
the saudi educational system you know
well it's a good example i think of the
point you make throughout the book that
that especially king faisal was very
interested in modernization without
westernization right and bin laden was
kind of a product of faisal's efforts in
that regard yes and i think the
brotherhood and
you may have interesting uh sort of
related
views about this but
it struck me as i came to understand the
way that the brotherhood in particular
was a framework for his indoctrination
that this syrian gym teacher who he had
in prep school he went as you know he
attended a very modernizing prep school
with with the boys wear blue blazers and
gray flannel
slacks and but after school there were a
lot of exiled uh
members of the muslim brotherhood
teaching in saudi arabia from syria and
egypt and and their
outlook and the and the doctrine that
they taught to young men like osama
was a little bit more sort of
politically inflected a little more
politically active than some of the
salafi traditional orthodox saudi
doctrine which was much more concerned
with the way you practice religious
rituals and the degree to which you
imitated the prophet muhammad's life
than it was
explicitly seeking violent overthrow of
apostate governments for instance
because in saudi arabia
that sort of talk is
rather thoroughly frowned upon
it's it it's a very good point in what
what struck me and i think i didn't
realize it as much as i should have
before i read your book is that
the brotherhood the muslim brotherhood
itself is not unlike al qaeda in that it
was it didn't go after
the poor and the un unpopular it went
after the cream of the crop absolutely
the best and the brightest yeah and and
even in for instance you know hamas
which is an expression of the
brotherhood
you know there they as they began to
compete with the secular palestinian uh
liberation organization derived groups
their strength was in the engineers
unions and the accountants and the
doctors and and that's the that's kind
of the pattern i think it's it's and
it's quite a ability i think for the
united states
uh
to keep believing that our enemies are
illiterate and
and poor and just if we could get them a
job if we if we could resurrect
heraldickis and have a new deal in the
middle east everything would be
hunky-dunky it's amazing how blind we
are to that fact yeah and and and it
goes to this sort of theme of
modernization too that we
that we sort of tend to think of anyone
who doesn't
uh sort of
follow a path of modernization into
secularization as as unmodern and and
that's you know i think the the
narrative of the of the bin ladens
belies that oh i think you just look at
mohammed bin laden as you as you so you
know thoroughly describe
a one-eyed
almost illiterate
um
yemeni ends up
the master of a huge construction empire
flying his own jets
and you know he he inspires i see him as
a sort of source of identity or
inspiration or at least modeling for
osama in in
in that way um
as a modern man that he's a source of
influence on osama but also there's this
this sense of that we were talking about
before we were talking about as an
immigrant of the way that he was able to
organize diverse followers in the
context of his construction company you
know these images of him working at the
dome of the rock in jerusalem with
italian catholics and palestinians and
lebanese and and
the camps that he would organize in the
saudi desert when he was building roads
with africans and pakistanis and afghans
and arabs and
and this um
sense of diversity but unified by islam
that was part of his genius as a
construction man and of course he was
more tolerant than his
son osama proved to be but osama's i see
osama's genius as a leader as located in
part in his ability to hold together and
attract such a diverse following pretty
unusual in the arab world to have
bangladeshis and filipinos and europeans
and others all steve you're exactly
right maybe unique in the in the muslim
world but it's on that point i thought
it was a
you you drew a very strong and i think a
very accurate
lineage between muhammad
the dad and osama bin laden and i just
put down a couple of things they're
they're both very interested and
concerned with details
very much hands-on people
uh very religious in their own way
different eras but still very religious
both workaholics and what i thought was
was very interesting is is although
muhammad turned out to be
a very wealthy man
you point out that he was not a
particularly acquisitive individual no
in fact like a lot of self-made men he
was
um he taught his children you know a
philosophy of denial and self-reliance
and
and he was apparently quite stingy with
their school allowances and and
concerned that they would be spoiled
and that's it's so interesting because
over the years
uh following bin laden
uh
big big issues were easy for him but he
really was a nickel and dime guy why do
you need 192 instead of only 168 dollars
which
unfortunately many people in the
american government kind of thought well
they must be poor right they weren't
right
but i i thought that was a very
worthwhile point
um
the what i came away with
too from from the book
is it within saudi society
of which the bin ladens are apart
there seems to be very little middle
on the one side you have a kind of a
militant
very religious group and on the other
side
for the one of a better word kind of a
debauched um
greedy
uh
not very
talented group of people who happen to
run the government
and it seems to me that that
that's a very odd situation in terms of
a of an elite
that there's only these two choices
there's there's not very many people in
the middle well but i in the in the bin
laden family that
was a you know a question that i was
continually
wrestling with where does identity flow
and and how do you think about these
different wings and and there there was
um
there did develop i think in the
generation to which osama belonged a
kind of center around bucker the
the the brother who took charge after uh
solomon and if there's anyone who sort
of represents an attempt to kind of
be a sort of bobbit of
saudi arabia it's it's you know bucker
gives you that impression he's he's a
pilot and he travels in the west but
he's not really of the west uh he's a
you know he's a pious man but he's also
not a a radical and he's and he's
overseeing um
the construction work in mecca and
medina with sort of the credit the
credibility of us of a saudi um sort of
mainstream businessman but
uh but it's i think you're right that
it's been very hard for saudi arabia to
organize around that that kind of
centrist blend because it's constantly
um
in question by the religious authorities
you know you it's very hard to establish
a center when
when so much of the government or the
establishment is
is um you know funded to to keep
a public
culture going around the most orthodox
interpretations yes of islam
it i i think that's exactly right um and
i i was struck
that in some ways the the the travel
from muhammad bin laden through his son
solemn back to uh
to backer is kind of
um in advance and then a return doctor
is much more his father's son than
solomon ever was exactly and and and
also uh
the passage of time and and the course
of a life perhaps has something to do
with that because of course solemn died
in 1988 in this ultralight accident
outside of san antonio and
he probably would have lived the way he
lived for the rest of his days but in
any event his life ended prematurely and
with a number of his brothers and
sisters that i was able to to understand
at least in outline form the sort of
fullness of their lives
and this is not unusual in america after
relatively free living periods in their
20s and 30s many of them at middle age
came back to saudi arabia came back to
its culture came back to its faith and
decided to try to rebalance their their
orientation and and bucker was the
vehicle for that sort of return and
regathering of the family around their
father's values it's f it's funny i came
away from reading your book uh
with the belief that really
the family the bin laden family under
muhammad and then under bakker
is much closer to the
type of family organization
that the religious establishment favors
then are the elsa oods really yeah
that's actually uh i think that's it's a
very it's very what came it seemed to me
very interesting that
the foreigners the yemenis
are much better saudis right than the
saudis
[Laughter]
but i think you're i think you're
exactly right backer is a very
impressive individual yes
like his father yes
solemn you know clearly kept things on
the tracks but
for all the bin laden organizations at
some point there could have been a bin
laden brothers for pimping and
and pagan entertainment
for the for the royal family right right
well they did have they did and this was
part of their status as sort of
subordinates and outsiders and
continually dependent on the saudi royal
family in order to succeed they had to
sort of act as a kind of concierge
service for the senate for the royals
very much so but you know what i came
away with stephen and you're the expert
and not me but i couldn't imagine
muhammad bin laden or backer
providing the same sort of or playing
the same sort of role that solemn did
right and and there was a kind of a
generational sort of
aspect of that in the sense that solemn
and the royals the younger princes that
he traveled with abroad and and and and
tried to keep happy and entertained the
era of king fod you know it was the it
was the period after the oil shock when
a certain generation of saudi elite
had the opportunity to purchase whatever
identity they wanted whatever play they
wanted and
and they kind of went
wild for a while and uh and solemn was
the instrument of of that but you know i
loved solemn in the course of getting to
know him i mean he's a terrorism
he's charismatic
and ultimately in the end in his own
personal choices a little more grounded
than some of the atmosphere around him
might suggest i mean he sort of
he he was he was fine whatever his
clients wanted to do that was fine but
he stayed home most nights watching
television and talking on the telephone
and and he was uh but he had this it's
this this passage this sort of streak of
charismatic genius that starts with the
father and finds its expression in its
most westernized form in solemn rock and
roll musician pilot adventurer very
americanized very american in the spirit
in the sense that he's a somebody who
travels likes to be on the move all the
time is that interested in making money
interested in making money and and also
um
a um
a very sort of free
um
an egalitarian person he's you know he
had no time for snobs he didn't like
palm beach there's that great scene in
the restaurant where some american
businessman he's with sends back a
bottle a glass of wine finding it
inadequate solemn excuses himself as if
he's going to the men's room goes into
the kitchen gets the
takes the waiter and says okay take that
bottle and pour it empty another bottle
pour it into that bottle and re-serve it
and
the guy says oh this is excellent why
and solomon catches him out i mean that
that i i think you know endeared him to
many americans this sort of sense of you
know he had no errors uh about about his
own wealth and privilege and that's very
much the connection between muhammad
bakker and osama and solomon is the
egalitarianism yes i think that that's
what makes these these
as you said these very unique uh
multinational organizations in the
islamic world work yes
absolutely yeah and you can't make that
up uh as a saudi because people come to
saudis certainly from places like india
and pakistan bangladesh and the
philippines with the assumption that
they're going to to get an attitude
because saudis
have not always conveyed a sense of
welcome egalitarian culture to their
guest workers in the kingdom and somehow
osama because of his father because of
the culture and the family was he really
lived that way yeah otherwise it
wouldn't have worked well even even as
western as solemn was the egalitarianism
of the yemenis of of that family at
least was essential to making his
yes his his business work and i think
it's very well explained in there and
again it's in that it's a kind of a
point that's almost american yes that
they're they're they're hustlers they're
egalitarian
you're you're not it's not so much your
family but what you achieve right that
matters right it's a very good story
i
uh on on the on the issue of osama
i often have wondered
on the process you talked about
the the business of as they grow older
they sometimes abandon some of the
the western leaning and come back the
other way
what do you think is the the current
uh
the
current relationship between osama and
his family the we have the the public
statements um i always remember him
smiling and kind of quietly saying one
time when he asked about his
relationship that that blood is thicker
than water right yes and and what did
you come away with well i mean it's you
know first we can start with the just
the sheer complexity of what we mean by
family because in his case he has
essentially three groups of relatives in
his life he has
the
family of
siblings the generation of 54 children
of bahamut bin laden to which he belongs
and that
family that group has now entered their
40s and 50s and early 60s and they're
organized around bucker and that's the
official family so there's that group
then there's his step family because of
course you remember his
mother
who was 14 when she married his father
was divorced from him shortly after
osama's birth and then muhammad arranged
for her remarriage
to a man who worked in his company a guy
who had a steady salary and
so osama grew up in her that sort of
step household in a
conventional almost conventional and
saudi context nuclear family at a
suburban house in jeddah and he ended up
with four or five step brothers and
sisters
one reason to clarify that distinction
is that we know for instance in early
2001 at the wedding of his son muhammad
in afghanistan that his mother and one
of his stepbrothers from that nuclear
household came to visit him so clearly
there was a line of contact with his
step family that extended well beyond
the period in the mid 90s when he was
formerly divested of his shareholdings
in the maine bin laden family and then
finally
he's had children he's had wives and
children and he's got sons running
around all over still today some of whom
have returned to saudi arabia and and
tried to rejoin uh you know have
rejoined saudi society as as businessmen
and so forth some appear to be in exile
with him and others are in ambiguous
states like his son sod is apparently
still under house arrest in iran yes so
it's a fascinating story isn't it you
know the one thing that comes across is
not only osama but his dad and solomon
they're very gentle people with their
own family yes there is this uh this
diffidence and and kind of quiet um
style i i suppose it you i find it uh
often in saudi arabia generally that
people speak very softly and yes and
there is a kind of a sense of reticence
uh that that is the most common form of
public uh culture solemn and muhammad
were both a little more jokey and caring
and loud and sort of willing to goof
around in comparison but osama didn't
take that part of the family
and he
he comes across as someone who's just uh
this is his setting sitting at a table
talking
but
you know almost as a seminar leader and
very quiet and when you see him in tapes
and you hear all the accounts of the way
he operates he's he's much more like a
political science seminar leader than
your average
very much
intimidating
terrorist
boss i think we're at the break good
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts
more with steve call and michael shoyer
is america the last defender of western
civilization
that's what mark stein asks in his book
america alone
author of the face of the tiger mr stein
writes the weekly happy warrior column
in the national review
sunday at 10 am book tv brings you an
interview with the author from c-span's
washington journal followed by live
calls where mark stein will answer your
questions about america's role in the
world
live with mark stein sunday at 10 a.m
eastern on book tv on c-span 2.
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts
more with steve call and michael
steven this in your very excellent book
we encounter a wide range of of people
bin ladens and al sauds and other
people who run in those circles
and one of the things that struck me uh
after reading the book is some of the
most
talented farsighted of them are
people who i think americans would
generally identify as being too islamic
i'm thinking particularly of baker bin
laden of muhammad bin laden certainly
osama but on the al-saud side king
abdul-aziz
the founder of the of the country
especially before he became before he
aged
and king faisal
a very austere and religious man
there seemed to be
maybe not an odd combination but a clear
combination between
um
principled intelligent men
and a strong islamic faith at least in
this environment right well i think it's
in this environment maybe as the is the
part of the answer to that
because
in a saudi context if you're going to
work hard and you're going to be
centered and you're going to
organize your life around purposeful
work it's very difficult to do that if
you don't do it as a faithful
muslim because the that's that's the
environment in which you are set and if
you if you spend a lot of your time and
energy trying to be something else then
that's going to take you away from
your
purpose in some sense and whether you're
interested in governing or building the
kingdom as faisal was or you're
interested in building a corporation a
company as the as many of the bin ladens
were it's it's a funny situation if king
faisal had not been assassinated one
wonders if if saudi arabia might not be
a much more modern state
than it is today yeah he he took him so
long to get started that was the thing
that was so striking about researching
re-researching the 50s was that that
long debilitating struggle with his
brother saud before he's finally able to
take control was a wasted decade there
in the 50s where really no
infrastructure was built none of
faisal's vision of modernization was
really started in a big way until until
the 60s and then he was tied down by
this war with nassar for so long and he
wasn't able to ever until
uh the early 70s he really wasn't able
to give his full attention to this
project that he had in mind and as you
say right at the point when the
geopolitics and the internal family
problems
fade away he's taken off the stage yeah
and it's interesting the only the only
really two saud al sauds that osama bin
laden has ever praised
were king faisal
and the crown prince before he became
king right i think they expect he
expected much from abdullah i don't not
sure they were he's been pleased with
himself right and there may not have
been realistic expectations yes but
during that period it's very interesting
because it that was the period when
osama was in sudan and
and uh there is this
this uh ambiguity about his sort of
ambition then when he's a family man and
he's a farmer and he's also funding
jihadi violence and gathering militias
and he's got some business interests and
he's living in a big house and he's got
a nice office and there's this sort of
sense of well what direction am i going
into we know for instance that he
applied for asylum in britain at one
point there were saudi dissidents out in
in britain and he was working with them
and writing his pamphlets you know his
angry pamphlets and one of the themes
this is when he starts distinguishing
between abdullah and the um and the
sudairis and particularly denouncing
sultan and fod but but leaving abdullah
in a different category
and
unfortunately osama doesn't leave us
with much commentary about his
relationship with his own family that
that's a great frustration
as a biographer
somebody asked me you know what would
you ask him if you could uh talk to him
and i would say can you come on give us
a little bit more but uh but there is a
if you uh read carefully uh his texts
and his comments where he comes close to
commenting about his family and and
abdullah and the and
and the royal family in saudi arabia
what you can see is a streak of ambition
in him
in which
he is seems to be imagining the
possibility that a proper king abdullah
a proper saudi arabia or saudi arabia
that really fulfilled faisal's
vision of modernization without
secularization might be a saudi arabian
which he would be
the great leader of the bin laden family
and the and the proper collaborator the
proper partner of a king abdullah and i
think that he's harboring this kind of
maybe i can have it all um
sort of possibility right up until
he's thrown out of sedan i i think i
think you're exactly right and i thought
and in the book is not i i don't want to
leave viewers with the impression that
it's only about osama but i thought your
book was a brilliant
development of osama's character over
time
starting out as as really as you said
the kind of
product the the hoped-for product of the
saudi educational saudi societal system
and growing over time and you know very
much it's a it's a warts on portrait he
made mistakes he had a very poor idea of
some things of how it operated in the
west but over time
the the emergence of an of a maturing
individual i think is a very a very
important uh point of in your book yes
and he also he has these you know he has
these great gifts that we've talked
about this charisma this ability to
build diverse coalitions its ability to
innovate with technologies of
globalization all of that explains why
he ended up
making himself the man that we're
talking about today but he does have
limitations in my judgment anyway and
and those are mostly of um intellect and
vision i mean he he's he's an intuitive
uh character all of the bin ladens have
an intuitive quality about their talent
but when he has to sort of sit down and
analyze
a complex set of geopolitical problems
he's not as accurate then as he as he is
effective with his intuition and that
leads him into his mistakes so
he seems to misunderstand at various
points
who what he's really dealing with in
various political contexts i think
that's exactly right and i but i do
think that he's
like his organization is kind of a
learning organization i think i think
it's very important the points you make
in the book about the kind of thirst for
information whether he integrates that
information accurately is a different
story right well i mean and after all as
we sit here and try to understand
the islamic world by reading
by watching al jazeera or reading the
arabic
we don't exactly get it we don't exist
on the first draft so
that's that's that's very true
i i wanted to um
to go for a moment into the into the
what i think is is presented very
clearly although understated
uh letting the reader decide for himself
i i just came away with the impression
from reading your book of the
almost easy going corruption
and not i'm not not just in the sense of
uh money
but in the sense of a willingness to
compromise principle between um
the american elite
in their dealings with with the saudis
right it's it just seems extraordinary
to me that
the access they have to the white house
if they have a problem um
jim baker or his son run to the to the
rescue or frank carlucci
it's uh
i think it's a
it's a very interesting
comment
on
the power of money even if it's unspoken
right and the mutual dependency between
the two elites that grew up and i
thought one thing that really struck me
about that material this time through
that i hadn't
really i mean part of my
desire and i wouldn't argue that i
achieved it fully but it was always
animating my work
was i wanted to try to push past what i
considered my own cliched understanding
of saudi arabia and its elites and its
complexity and so we all in the oil era
inherited this
narrative of the greedy shake you know
the cartoons and the papers of the guys
standing by the gas pump making us
miserable and so forth and
so
when you get into this texture of the
relationship between the two elites of
course the first thing that you're
reminded is that
that the
corruption flowed in both directions
so where do you get the idea of how
a
irresponsible prince
might spend his wealth well there's
these scenes where that where the oil
companies bring king saud to new york
when i mean the guy's never been
anywhere he has no formal education and
they they bring him to the waldorf
astoria and put you know chinese
tumblers and dancers and and you know a
big uh toy train in front of him and
then they mock him for you know being
enamored of all of this luxury well you
know it's it's it's not good enough and
a lot of the the sort of uh culture of
mutual corruption and dependency um
you know flows in in both directions
absolutely it's a it's a story of you go
along to get along right
it's it
you know there's no other way to kind of
explain it uh the fact that we have done
virtually nothing
uh about energy dependence since the
first oil embargo which probably king
faisal didn't intend to be a
a life preserver thrown to america but
it was we just happened not to grab it
right
right but it's it's an extraordinary
story and i think for americans it's got
to be a very disturbing story yeah and
the whole thing is you know kind of runs
on automatic pilot and is and is very
much deliberately sequestered and
secluded uh from
um review uh you know it sort of lies a
lot of foreign policy uh finds its way
into national debates and and into the
system in one way or another but somehow
this relationship
uh has has it's it's like a kind of a
privately held company that isn't
subject to financial or other kinds of
disclosures well you know
that's exactly right and and
the one area where there is very seldom
any leaks from a government in the
united states democratic or republican
is our relationship with the saudis
and they can't they'll sacrifice
american lives if they if if leaking can
give them a political advantage but not
this issue yeah and and as you know from
your time in government i'm sure you
have your own uh stories of this kind
but i remember talking to somebody who
was in the national security council in
the 90s and and we were talking about
these broader strategic questions of you
know who are the saudi who are the
saudis what is our relationship with
them should we asce what is the
stability of the country how do you
assess all of this and yes i was sort of
saying because i was looking as a
researcher well who wrote this down
weren't there
estimates or debates or weren't there
memos arguing about this and he said we
could talk about it but we were always
told don't put it in right
which is it's which is an interesting uh
comment
because i think uh one
there's very few heroes in your book
the one hero of mine before i read your
book
and still is even more today is a fbi
special agent named dan coleman
who
i think when americans read your book
their their if they find a hero among
the americans in the book dan coleman is
it yes absolutely he was the one who was
willing to take on not only the
bin ladens and the elsa oods but the
mighty powerful law firms that protect
them in our country yes
and that he didn't mind expressing his
irritation about the whole uh dan is
among the most decent honorable men that
i've ever met and
the whole business of of your comment
about not writing it down
this is one area that i wanted to get
into just just a bit because of course
the 911 commission
was a disastrous thing for america but
more especially
it kind of ignored the saudi problem
and
the the willingness of americans to
senior americans important americans to
cover for the saudis
is is um extraordinary and i wanted to
to just read one short paragraph
quoting a couple of people um
and this was in what part of it was in
response to something i told you
and this is john brennan who was a very
senior
person
at cia and now is a i think an advisor
to barack obama
and senator weich fowler who was the
ambassador to saudi arabia before 9 11.
it says
there was never a reluctance on our part
to ask questions of the saudis brennan
said later responding to shoyer's
criticisms
added white fowler the ambassador from
the moment backer bin laden agreed to my
requests for the family's cooperation
they provided the treasury department
and the fbi access to their books and
family records and their contract with
the us military on its base in saudi
arabia was not terminated
further this is mr fowler talking i
never heard a complaint from our
government about their lack of
cooperation now i can tell you both of
those men are lying steve
and
i can tell you that the documents exist
that would prove them to be lying but
this is the typical response of american
officials when they're asked about the
saudis because as you said they don't
think the documents are going to be
they're they don't write things down
themselves
and when the things that are written
down they never expect them to be
released to the public so they get away
with this right
well there's this whole you know the
narrative that you're drawing uh on
there is
you know
barely outlined i would say by my own
research even though i was able to kind
of push past uh the last place it was
left off you know what i mostly came
away with was the was the sense of
absolutely being flabbergasted
about the mystery of what actually had
happened here i mean for instance this
is a basic factual question which i
certainly could not resolve to my own
satisfaction as the as the back and
forth there reflects which is
you know there were
contacts between the american government
and the bin laden family in which the
american government asked for
cooperation
and you have dan coleman's experience
which he describes on the record of the
book as a generally quite a frustrating
one and and then you have
uh wise fowler's assertion on the record
that they actually opened up their books
now you know in the bin laden family
does have a very complex set of
financial offshore
companies and international investments
that are all privately held they're not
subject to financial disclosures so they
would have to be voluntarily disclosed
yes i couldn't find any evidence that
that was actually disclosed but but but
the but the record describing what did
and didn't happen
is 95 unavailable that's absolutely the
case and i have to tell you that i was
there for
the better part of a decade working on
this issue and i never saw any
information from the bin laden family
now maybe it was passed to the fbi and
it didn't get down to the agency i don't
know but
um
but you think dan would know anyway dan
yeah dan is uh if if he says he was
frustrated with the lack of cooperation
you can take that to the bank
because he's a very very honest man
it's just uh
it's one of those issues that i think
americans generally need to know about
and i don't have a clue about how
they're going to get to know about it i
think your your book clearly advances
the ball
but still not to the point where
you know we can never
underst i i think it's very difficult
for an american to take my opinion for
example that before
9 11 the saudis were the enemy they
protected bin laden
but you know i know that the people who
worked with us knew that
how do you document it when everything
was classified right which is a a huge
problem well in time i hope the records
will come out i think so you know i i
think that's very well in my recent book
what i tried to do is to point everybody
who wanted to find out
if what i was saying was true toward a
freeman of information act that would
result in the documents but i i don't
know if that's going to work
but i think
one while we're talking about documents
i i think the one thing that that is
extraordinarily impressive about this
book is the amount of research
and also the arcane nature of the
research you had to do so
if you could describe that i think
readers would be fascinating well with
the life of muhammad would you know
basically i started out with there was
only a thing your original
the book you read as anonymous uh had
one good
outline of his life and and there were
one or two other places where people had
tried to get a sense of his life but i
was hoping to write you know
100 pages about it
yeah and yeah and i wasn't and i wasn't
sure where i was going to find that so
actually a friend of mine said well i'll
bet you if you go out to the archives
and you're willing to just dig through
all of the
declassified cables that came out of the
jedi embassy between 1945 and his death
in 1967
that you'll find references to him
particularly from the economic sections
and from other people who were just
doing routine business
and so i started that it was like
digging through huge piles of straw
looking for and i learned to scan
because you know the americans we keep
everything the brits call their uh
archives only one out of ten telegrams
is retained in the by the foreign office
but the but the u.s system they you have
to read everything uh the plane of the
arriving commerce deputy is 15 minutes
late the plane has landed the car has
been dispatched the meeting is occurring
in 20 minutes and so you just keep
flipping and flipping and you learn to
kind of scan for the name bin laden and
what was astonishing was that there was
so much in the american archive about
his life and every time you'd find a
memo of a conversation or a cable about
a deal you'd get another nugget of
understanding and so then to go from the
college park archives to the british
foreign office eventually the german uh
because the germans are pretty good
about keeping records uh if only the
italians
were as meticulous because there were a
lot of italians in his organization
anyway it turned out that there was a
there was quite a full uh record
frustrating in places because i remember
there was one cable that a british
ambassador to saudi arabia wrote
about mohammed bin laden and he was
saying some interesting things but he he
paused and said now my full views about
muhammad's relationship with the saudi
royal family were laid out in telegram
number 375 so i won't repeat them here
and it was one of the ones they thrown
away
you also did a tremendous amount of
research in legal documents yeah it
turned out that uh
the
generation of assam osama's generation
were heavily present united states
they were
mostly in florida texas california and
boston
and so as an old newspaper investigative
reporter i just went to all those places
and started going into the county
court archives looking for civil suits
because in the american system records
of civil cases are wide open and so you
end up with
business disputes that seem like they're
trivial and small but then you start
getting information from the documents
that are filed and the pleadings and the
depositions and then there were a few
big cases that turned out to be very
informative like a divorce case in los
angeles where the ex-wife
had hired a forensic accountant to go to
saudi arabia to figure out whether this
half-brother of osama was telling her
the truth about his income and it was
one of the few sort of formal
investigations that somebody actually
undertook in the early 90s so i was
often sitting down in in courthouses in
orlando or los angeles and i'd come
across something like that and i
just wanted to you know eureka
and of course there's all these poor
people just kind of getting records for
their divorces or something nobody was
very interested in what i was doing
but i had a great deal of fun doing and
then the last piece of it was finding
people who had known solomon in
particular yes you know i'd always been
interested in this question of
um who did who what americans did osama
ever actually meet okay so the record
shows that he never had direct contact
with any cia officers i have never been
able to find and neither did i we we
searched the agency's archives in
1995 and 96 and frankly to make sure we
were we were
misinforming people we're covering
ourselves yes and so and so we know he's
met some journalists later uh but but i
was thinking you know who who did he who
might he have met and uh
so it turned out that when solemn was
dealing collaborating with osama in the
mid 80s when everybody was on the same
team he used to travel up to peshawar
with these shaggy-haired
rock and roll playing mechanics swedes
and yes and the one american who
the book describes meeting osama was a
salesman of ultralight recreational
aircraft who played the guitar who
solemn had
invited on a hunting trip with saudi
royals to pakistan and then in the
middle of the hunting trip he said well
we got to go up and meet my brother
osama because he needed to give him some
money and take some video of what he was
doing up there
and
so i'd heard this story from other
people who'd been on the trip and
i tracked the the um
the name down and it was in houston and
and i went to his house at nine in the
morning and knocked on the door and just
said you know i'm a journalist and i'm
researching this life and
and uh his his wife was very pleasant
and said
george someone's here about the bin
ladens and
and he came and he was very gracious and
quite wonderful and talked on the record
in the book but he came to the door and
he said i explained myself and he said
i've been waiting six years for
youtubers
these people had these random
connections with the bin ladens but many
of them remembered them very fondly and
i the one thing i would say about the
family too because you can't
invent uh
a credit rating i mean either you have
good credit or you don't have good
credit and in in a business and human
sense that's also true and if you run a
company
uh you'll either leave behind people who
are loyal to you and who felt that they
were well treated or you'll leave behind
a lot of people who are angry and who
felt that uh you know they were poorly
treated either in business or in their
personal interactions
and the bin lads left behind a lot of
people who were very loyal to them and
who and who had genuine affection and
respect for the family yeah and i and i
think that's right and i think that's
the a very important point in the book
that this is the whole egalitarian
strain of of this family and and they're
very american-like
hustling hustling in the sense in a good
sense yes it's a very
very important uh point i want just one
other question as we end or come close
to ending
were you able to find any former u.s
official
senior u.s official
who had anything bad to say about
the saudis or the bin ladens i i came
across uh in your book which fowler and
chaz freeman and
phil griffin
and uh
it's extraordinary
the
the degree to which
a senior american officials come back
from serving
in saudi arabia enamored with an
enormously corrupt
and uh
obviously uh anti-american family that
rules that country well i think all of
the dissent comes from the middle of the
bureaucracy uh you know essentially
where where people like your uh you
resided and you had your careers who
were focused on ct and weren't focused
on relationship management and so
certainly your
views are not isolated but they but they
but they're not very common at the top
of the system they're not and i think
that's what i tried to express earlier
though that i that what i came away with
was the feeling of
kind of mutual corruption between the
two the elites of the two countries and
not money who knows if there's how much
money goes back and forth but
corruption in the sense of compromising
principles you know the man james baker
who is uh you know an architect of of
the destruction of the evil empire to be
someone who's eager to defend
um the saudis against claims by
americans or other people it's just an
extraordinary situation and it's oil and
it's oil it has to be what i mean what
else would explain it yes you know you
can call in when you can call in
former presidents former secretaries of
state and they always are defending
the saudis it's it's a
very interesting situation
again um
i think it's a wonderful book
the uh
the couple of things that i would say
again that americans should pay
particular attention to is the the the
the fact that being religious in the
saudi sense does not mean you're not
talented
which
comes across very clearly in everyone
from king faisal to osama bin laden and
the stark
differentiation in the muslim mind
between modernization and secularization
i think those are extraordinarily
important things and you you you
i think rather magnificently handle
these in the book
thank you michael yeah it's a i hope it
has a i hope it sells it ought to sell a
tremendous number of books and i think
it should interest americans very much
both in how muslims look at us and
interact with each other but also the
difference between the perceptions of
the average american and their elites
regarding our relationship with the
muslim world
so congratulations thank you
this has been afterwards with steve cole
surely america's most knowledgeable and
insightful author regarding
not only saudi arabia but pakistan and
afghanistan
and i can't recommend his book simply
called the bin laden's too highly thank
you steve thank you michael conversation
[Music]